[Musique]
l'aspirine est le médicament le plus
consommé dans le monde
il s'en produit environ 40 mille tonnes
par année soit près de 80 milliards de
comprimés les propriétés multiples de
l'aspirine en font un médicament
privilégié pour traiter toutes sortes de
problèmes de santé il est aussi
régulièrement prescrits par les médecins
pour prévenir les maladies
cardiovasculaires
or cette utilisation est de plus en plus
remise en question on en a tous un
flacon quelque part pour soigner les
bobos du quotidien petite douleur
inflammation fièvre c'est aussi un
anticoagulant dans les vaisseaux l'acide
acétylsalicylique aspirine empêche
l'agrégation des plaquettes qui peut
former des caillots et bloquer la
circulation sanguine pour cette raison
l'aspirine est souvent prescrite pour
prévenir les maladies cardiovasculaires
comme l'infarctus où l'accident
vasculaire cérébral
l'imbécile
à l'institut de cardiologie et de
pneumologie de québec
la cardiologue marie-eve piché prescrit
régulièrement de l'aspirine à ses
patients essentiellement des gens qui
ont déjà souffert de ce type de maladie
c'est ce qu'on appelle la prévention
secondaire chez des individus qui ont
déjà eu un événement cardiovasculaire
on sait que bénéfices avec une
diminution de la mortalité
cardiovasculaire mais également un
bénéfice au niveau de la diminution de
réciter d'événements cardiovasculaires
mais des gens prennent aussi
régulièrement de l'aspirine alors qu'ils
n'ont jamais eu de maladie
cardiovasculaire
on parle alors de prévention primaire
une petite dose d'aspirine par jour à
partir de 50 ans au cas où
c'était pratique courante jusqu'à
récemment il ya pas si longtemps - dix
ans
on voyait de façon régulière
on encourager la prise d'aspirine sur
une base régulière une faible dose en
prévention aux primaires de maladies
cardiovasculaires c'est même suggéré sur
certains produits vendus sans ordonnance
pourtant l'utilité de l'aspirine dans
les terres de prévention primaire est de
moins en moins évidente
des études récentes conclu que le jeu
n'en vaut pas la chandelle
ces trois grandes études ont démontré
une diminution plutôt modeste du risque
cardiovasculaires associés à la prise
d'aspirine en prévention primaire et une
augmentation assez importante du risque
de saignement majeur d'où un rapport
bénéfice/risque beaucoup moins
avantageux en réduisant la coagulation
l'it et du sang l'aspirine peut
provoquer des saignements graves en
particulier dans le système digestif
selon une analyse de traits études
cliniques menées avec des patients qui
ne souffraient pas de maladies
cardiovasculaires ces risques de
saignements surpasse les bénéfices
potentiels de l'aspirine sur dix mille
patients qui ne prenaient pas d'aspirine
61 on tue un problème cardiovasculaire
sur 10000 qui en prenait régulièrement
57 ont une telle maladie 4 de moins
c'est peu mais significatif l'aspirine a
donc un effet protecteur modeste
cependant sur dix mille patients qui ne
prenaient pas d'aspirine 16 ont souffert
de saignements majeurs contre 23 chez
ceux qui en prenait 7 de plus à la
lumière de ces grandes études on ne
suggère plus de routine
la recommandation d'aspirine en
prévention primaire pour nous ça vient
changer la pratique clinique
[Musique]
l'association qui regroupe les
cardiologues américains vient justement
de réviser ces lignes directrices sur la
prévention primaire des maladies
cardiovasculaires l'aspirine n'est plus
recommandé
sauf dans de rares cas
[Musique]
les spécialistes suggèrent plutôt de
s'attaquer aux facteurs de risque
associés aux maladies cardiovasculaires
comme le cholestérol l'obésité le
diabète ou l'hypertension ensuite que
j'aime me farah sur un pis aller faire
suite à son décès drosson a besoin
d'intervenir au mur et la tension
artérielle soit avec la médication ou
avec l'alimentation l'activité physique
est ce que vous êtes actif dans le petit
bleu à l'institut de cardiologie québec
les patients sont suivis par des
médecins mais aussi des kinésiologues
qui leur suggère des programmes
d'entraînement
ils reçoivent aussi les conseils de
nutritionnistes ou encore d'infirmières
pour arrêter de fumer
l'idée c'est que le traitement le plus
efficace pour le coeur c'est d'avoir de
bonnes habitudes
c'est une prise en charge globale du
risque cardiovasculaire donc on va
évaluer le bénéfice de plusieurs
interventions beau vouloir intervenir au
niveau de l'activité physique au niveau
de l'alimentation au niveau du poids au
niveau de l'arrêt tabagique au niveau du
contrôle la tension artérielle du
contrôle du profil des lipides c'est
vraiment une approche qui est globale et
très personnalisé aussi j'aurais pu
aller tranquillement sans que je perçois
aucun essoufflement des approches plus
payante d'un point de vue préventif que
la prise régulière d'aspirine
ce qui ne veut pas dire que ceux qui en
prennent devrait cesser de le faire
un passant
ne devrait jamais cessé on aspire et
unsa étaient prescrits et la même chose
devrait jamais débuté de l'aspirine en
prévention primaire
sa peau était prescrit aussi parce
qu'elle y est restée encore même très
très important dans le doute
dieu vous comme toujours consulter son
médecin
et nous